in the following table is y a function
of x in order for y to be a function of
x for any x that we input into our
little function box so let's say this is
y as a function of x it needs to spit
out at only only one value of y if it
spit out multiple values of y then it
might be a relationship but it's not
going to be a function so this is a
function
this is a function if we had a situation
where if we input x into a box it could
be multiple possible y's then this is
not
not a function so let's think about this
table right over here when x is equal to
we get y is equal to 1 but when x is
equal to 1 again all of a sudden y is
equal to 2. so here we have a situation
where we input 1 into our little
relationship box and when we input 1 to
our relationship box we could get a 1 or
we could get a 2 for y so this is
definitely not a function for any input
into a function it has to map to exactly
one output here it's mapping to two
outputs so this is not a function